it'll definitely motivate you i mean if
you're if you're a competitor and you
get so close to your ultimate goal
um and then you fall short i mean it's
something that will motivate you for the
rest of your career
i mean uh it was a it was a bad feeling
in that locker room after the game
i mean you don't want to have that
feeling again and so uh uh
we luckily enough well we'll have a lot
of the same guys back
um and we'll obviously add new guys and
and uh we'll set the tone from the
beginning of the year beginning of the
off season um that we have to be
better we'd be better than we were this
last year in order to go out there and
win the super bowl
yeah no cigarettes in fresca in the
locker room
at halftime or after this one for the
kansas city chiefs although they lost
the one where len dawson was smoking the
cigarette and drinking the fresca at
halftime that was super bowl
one the torment from losing
i think that drives tom brady and i
think now that patrick mahomes has a
dose of that
that torment that i never want to feel
this way
again ever in my life that that that's
that can be overwhelming it can be
overwhelming i mean
when i i'd have to look at the full list
of super bowls i mean how many guys have
we seen back in the super bowl recently
who have lost
one typically you don't get back if you
lose one
right right other than brady right who
who man established that
the torment from brady has carried him i
think to more victories
yeah right one twice of course but uh
but he's but i'm the guy's in the league
now who in the league now other than
mahomes and brady have lost one
and and come back russell wilson hasn't
gotten back yet
no and who knows if he's going to
there's some
something weird going on with russell
wilson and the seahawks you know they
haven't been past the division around
since their super bowl appearance when
they lost to the patriots
seven years ago now and he's going to be
33 this year so
i'm for my homes my point is this to get
that
lesson of his career because
uh what we always have the dan marino
caveat
well there's no guarantee you're ever
getting back do we really think patrick
mahomes isn't going to be back at some
point
do we really think at some point over
the next 15 years
he's not going to be back in the super
bowl his point is the motivation that
you get
from that loss is going to come in handy
we need to remember that
i hope i'm alive for the moment the next
time patrick mahomes is getting ready
for a super bowl
because i think the the very very bad
memories of what happened
on sunday could end up being the
difference maker for him yeah
it'll make him more obsessive i think
you know really that that's what it's
going to do
because you it is one of those i have
i'm not even
i've lost one playoff game in my life
played in one playoff game and it still
bothers me in my stomach when i think
about it so i can't even imagine winning
a super bowl
and doing that and are losing a super
bowl and having to deal with that
and yes i would think that makes them
more obsessive certainly
and listen i don't think it's that crap
i'll run that game back one more time
you tell me next year the chiefs can
have their starting offensive line
healthy and my home's healthy
i'd love to watch that game one more
time that'll be a different show it'll
be a different you know
we got to remember they had a jumble
around
three of their five linemen and play
them in positions they weren't used to
playing
in one game the whole year and it was
the biggest game of the year against the
best d-lineman they played all year
so that really that hurt them the timing
of all of that
was certainly you know handicapped to a
degree there and we'll see where it goes
but i still think like you said
mahomes the chiefs very relevant not
going anywhere
gonna be in the thick of things again
next year and this is reminding me of a
story
from a few years ago and it's not
ideally the
the best example but i remember jameis
winston talking about being at the pro
bowl
and he's at the breakfast buffet and
he's loading up a plate
of the usual breakfast food and he sees
russell wilson and someone else coming
back from a workout
and that's when the light bulb went off
because jameis was a little doughy back
in those days that's when the light bulb
went off for him that if i'm going to
really make something myself
i got to go next level now and look i
don't i don't want to assume that
jameis winston isn't going to become a
starting quarterback again but my point
is this
is patrick mahomes accepting in the
aftermath of this game
that he's got to give himself
completely to the sport the way that tom
brady does
if he wants to be tom brady if he wants
to establish that legacy of greatness
he's got to do the pliability he's got
to do the avocado ice cream it's got to
be pm15
to match tb12 if he really wants to do
it
the way that tom brady is doing it and
maybe what he saw on
on sunday and what he's witnessing and
what we're all witnessing from brady is
the
the challenge to all of them to echo
what you were saying earlier
if you're going to ever have a chance to
be the kind of player that tom brady
was and still is you got to come you got
to surrender yourself to it yeah you got
to be
so selfish about your career but at the
same time you've got to surrender all of
your own selfish impulses of i'd like to
eat that
i'd like to drink that i'd like to do
this i'd like to do that
instead of all the things that brady
does it feels like 24 hours a day
no and it it's and it's not going to be
easy but yeah it's going to take that
type of obsession for him to get to that
spot to where yeah he's competing with
him compared against him
whatever it is but it's a different
thing all together
and that's where it's just going to be
interesting to go all to again because
my home's kansas city is built around my
homes and it's all about mahomes and his
skill set
you know tom brady got the benefit of
team and coaching and i just got to play
a big part
in this whole thing we do right that's
where it's going to be a different
challenge for
patrick mahomes it's more like hey
patrick it's on you that's the way they
play that's the way kansas city is
and brady he just had to make sure he
was able to stay in shape stay sharp
mentally get ready
and as long as i can run this machine
we're going to be tough to beat
and that's where it's a different animal
to me all together because
more of it is just on my homes to do
things with his
great ability and not to take away from
the greatness of brady
but hey you know a lot of the things we
talk about that he's learned and he's
done he was taught by the greatest coach
of all time
you know he's the one that can go that's
the reason he can go to tampa bay and go
hey i think we should do this this and
this let me tell you why
and it's tom brad and it's bill
belichick and josh mcdaniel is coming
out of his mouth to bruce arians and all
that too
so those are the challenges mahomes is
really going to have to deal with
and i don't know if anybody could be as
obsessive as tom brady with all that it
takes to get it done
do we remember when it was that the
switch flipped for brady
to make him into this this cyborg this
football cyborg
when was it i i i'm gonna say
i feel like when they got into hey we're
gonna stop playing
run the ball defense team football and
around that 2006 time i want to say in
2007
when i feel like that's when they
started getting to hey let's ride brady
the rules the way they are and
everything like that as far as
you know favoring the offensive pass
game let's start doing that and i feel
like that was around the start
maybe right around there but i feel like
it went to another level of like
health and cyborg somewhere around 2012
and 13 to where it went off to another
jump
jumping spot of hey i'm psycho and i'm
doing everything i got to do
but now i've looked in deeper and i got
to go a little more cycle with my diet
my workout regimen and all that i feel
like that was around 2013-14
i don't know what do you think i i think
that's about right it was some time
after the acl
tear and it just he just just all of a
sudden he complained he bought into this
idea of playing until he's 45 and
and and that my point is mahomes has
seen that we've witnessed that
at some point the guys who truly want to
be like tom brady are going to have to
sign over their soul to a certain extent
their preferences their lifestyle
and be like tom brady if they're gonna
have a chance of doing that all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports